[Music]
you know i when i stopped at a smoothie
place on the way here i've been eating
like [ __ ] so i was like i gotta you know
drink a smoothie before going through a
smoothie and that is crazy yes and let
me tell you that [ __ ] you just [ __ ] it
out it's supposed to be healthy but it's
then you're sitting there and it's all
just comment like it's diarrhea why
didn't we turn the gravity on in the
bathrooms yeah
oh yeah so i'm diarrhea and it's just
floating around my head and it's getting
in my face back into your ass a little
bit dude so uh actually this is a great
segue into the story i wanted to tell
you the super bowl party that i went to
and let me just preface this by saying
it is true i think that i have to do
that now but this is a 100 real story it
is
i don't do that you know when jared goff
was there yeah i'm sure here's the thing
i didn't [ __ ] lie about the story
that i told no you're right gary
verified it was all true yeah but now
you're telling me a story so i'm at this
party and then larry david walks yeah
this is literally from a sitcom okay so
i'm hanging out with young sheldon right
so i'm at the
cameo super bowl party big ass house in
beverly hills and uh it's like a
real party there's security there's
clearances you can't go to certain
floors you can't get down hallways
whatever luckily i know the people who
started cameo right so kind of like uh
you know i'm at like the all-access
level you can sit in the master bedroom
sitting there mid super bowl and i'm all
of a sudden i'm like okay i gotta i
gotta poop but there's like two
bathrooms and they both have gigantic
lines i'm like not doing not [ __ ]
with that right i know the guys have
started this [ __ ] joint
so i go to him i go to devin i'm like
hey dude can i like use the bathroom
down the hallway and he's like yeah for
sure for sure he brings me down the
security lady is like okay yeah go ahead
you're with him cool and he lets me go
down to the bathroom in one of the
private bedrooms his bedroom i think is
where he stays when he's there taking
care of business dropping the kids off
at the pool i'm [ __ ] i'm sitting
there i'm on my phone you know doing
whatever maybe playing wordle and all of
a sudden i hear two female voices oh and
all of a sudden they open the door no no
no i
forgot to lock it i thought i was over
there alone i thought it was the
exclusive area right so they see my pale
thigh all they see is one thigh they
open the door and they go oh my god i'm
so sorry and then close the door and i
hear some giggling oh my god i can't
believe it no you can't even [ __ ] no i i
continued to shoot okay
i was fine i got no shame about that but
it's just like just seeing me in that
vulnerable position yeah
i'm just like this they open the door
yeah
like that and so but you know i hear
them kind of leave so i'm like okay cool
pretty embarrassing but i'll finish up
my business and you know keep my chin
high and i'll walk up like nothing
happens wipe
take out my pants turn around and flush
and the water just starts raising
perfect doesn't go down goes up just
starts raising like this and doesn't go
down no no no no no no no no no
and it gets like up to almost to the
seat and then it starts leaking back
down but none of the [ __ ] or none of the
toilet paper goes down okay maybe i
flushed it wrong maybe it's one of those
ones you have to hold it so i hold it
and it gets all the way up to the thing
and then stops and does not go down this
time the [ __ ] thing is clogged are
you kidding me this is already the worst
day of my life and now this [ __ ]
toilet is clogged nobody's here i'm in a
private bathroom i close the lid
and i
put my chin high
and i walk out of the room and i'm like
about to go left down the hallway and i
hear two voices and i i look to the
right and it's the two girls and they're
standing there like kind of giggling and
i was like hey sorry about that and
they're like no problem it's all good
and i'm like okay and i as i'm leaving i
kind of like look behind me and they go
in there after me and then later adam
like the guy who like runs i don't know
what he does he's worked for cameo
forever but he was in charge of the
party basically he's texting devin like
dude there's major sewage issues at the
house we had to stop the party because
it's like leaking out of like all sides
of the house
and devon was like this is because of
you and it wasn't it wasn't actually
because of me but that's the reason why
i wasn't flushing i just imagine you
going out of the bathroom and the entire
super bowl party is lined up in that
hallway they stopped watching the game
and then the two girls are like that's
that's the guy and then they're like
oh it's a poopy pants i heard you
clogged the toilet [ __ ] boy look at him
it wasn't even that big of a [ __ ] yeah
it was just the biggest poop we've ever
seen no it wasn't it was something
[ __ ] no there was like they were
little deer poops i swear
okay
so bad in there if we're ruining
everyone's saturday i'll just throw them
out there while we're at it oh you you
have a poop story i mean you know past
couple weeks have been intense just with
the amount of flights i've taken yeah
right taking a lot of plane shits
which you know apparently is like a
taboo no it's not i didn't think so
either yeah anyone who says that is
young i told tom i was like yeah i had
to drop one on the plane he was like oh
man he's like that's crazy dude even i
don't do that oh come on that's what i
thought but um i so i put on my story
what i've been eating at night and it's
these like hiking meals okay because i
just refuse to eat the late night food
anywhere i'm at i'm just not doing it do
you order them uh
is there a company that makes these
things yeah you bring them with you yeah
okay wait look let me let me get the
brand you have to microwave them
no you don't it's even darker than that
so it's just like it's just like uh it's
not like saving a cup of diarrhea it's
very different so mountain house uh i
read
some like comments somewhere some dudes
like yeah i ate this [ __ ] for six months
i was living off grid that's all i ate
these are awesome basically what you do
is like it's like astronaut food and you
put in two cups of hot water and it's
like a resealable bag so you open it you
put the hot water and you close it
and it's self microwaves because of the
material on the inside oh cool you open
it up and it's dude it's good food it's
not shitty at all
it doesn't taste shitty like didn't
taste greasy or anything and it's warm
oh yeah it's like a hot meal and it's
[ __ ]
delicious so
i've been eating these post show
every time i eat them tom or like he'll
like
like prep them he'll be like uh
i think i added too much water it kind
of looks like slop i'm like nah it's
good i'll just sit there
yeah it's pretty gross but so whatever
there were a couple nights where i
didn't do that and i settled for like
some you know shitty ass food around
town and it's crazy how
like weak your stomach gets after
25 years old yeah you know it's just
like i ate like two bison burgers in
omaha and i'm like oh my stomach hurts
and so to like push it out i ate like
several protein bars over many days and
you know i was backed up in there oh
okay you know i'm like come on a little
fiber yeah yeah a little more fiber now
come on boys let's i got him from one
place
and he was like how are you feeling like
i got a bathroom
sit down and i just feel my like all my
organs inside just like go into the
toilet just
finally i was just a brain and spine it
came out and i was just like
you're kidding me your lungs everything
everything dude i have your heart
everything's in the toilet i literally
kill myself yeah [ __ ]
elena had to call the ambulance and they
had to take all my organs and take my
hospital and put me back together
oh i feel like a new man yeah literally
they're like you are we had to like use
a bunch of transplants
you're not who you
were just turned inside out man
[Laughter]
[Music]
my skin and face is like sucked in like
i lost like a hundred years of life
oh walk out there's two girls waiting
there you're like
me you're gonna love what i left for you
in there and i just fall face first
just just like winnie the pooh just a
t-shirt in my ass out just
flat on my face
wow must have been a bad one
you